>>> MIGRANTS BY THE BUS LOAD
CONTINUE TO ARRIVE DAILY INTO
NEW YORK CITY FROM TEXAS,
STRAINING SHELTERS THAT WERE
ALREADY DEALING WITH
OVERCROWDING ISSUES.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
ACCUSED TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT OF FORCING MIGRANTSEN TO
THE BUSES.
ADAMS SAID MANY OF THE MIGRANTS
ENDURED 45 HOUR BUS RIDES WITH
LIMITED STOPS, EVEN THOUGH HE
SAYS SOME WANTED TO GO TO AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT STATE.
JOINING US NOW IS NEW YORK
CITY'S MAYOR ERIC ADAMS.
SIR, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU, GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU THIS MORNING.
>> SO THIS IS A BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN YOU AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT
AND HERE IS WHAT ABBOTT SAID
ABOUT IT.
>> I KIND OF FEEL LIKE CLINT
EASTWOOD, GO AHEAD, MAYOR, MAKE
MY DAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT IS
UNFORTUNATE HE BELIEVES THIS IS
A HOLLYWOOD SCRIPT AND IT IS
NOT.
IT IS LIVES OF HUMAN BEINGS.
AND TO WATCH A GOVERNOR LACK
COORDINATION AND SHOW THE
HUMANITARIAN ASPECTS OF OUR
COUNTRY, PLACING PEOPLE ON A
BUS, WITHOUT ADEQUATE WATER,
WITHOUT ADEQUATE FOOD, SENDING
THEM TO CITIES AND IN MANY CASES
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE, THIS IS NOT WHO WE ARE
AS AMERICANS.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE HIS DAY.
I WANT TO MAKE THE DAY OF THOSE
HE IS TREATING IN THIS
INHUMANITARIAN FASHION.
>> YOU SAY THEY'RE ARRIVING
WITHOUT HAVING ADEQUATE FOOD AND
WATER.
HOW ARE THEY ARRIVING TO NEW
YORK CITY IN YOUR KNOWLEDGE?
>> THE CONDITIONS ARE REALLY
DEPLORA
DEPLORABLE.
I MET A GROUP OF MIGRANTS ON
SUNDAY.
IT WAS CLEAR THE CONDITIONS WERE
INHUMANE.
WHEN YOU'RE ON A BUS FOR THAT
LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND YOU
DON'T -- CAN'T STOP AS NEEDED AS
MUCH, AND THE LACK OF
COORDINATION, CRISIS REALLY
CALLS ON US TO COORDINATE.
HE HAS NOT COORDINATED WITH THE
CITY OR STATE AT ALL.
AND IN FACT HE DENIED HE WAS
DOING THIS AT FIRST UNTIL IT WAS
REVEALED AND HE FINALLY ADMITTED
HE WAS SENDING PEOPLE OUTSIDE TO
THE STATE OF TEXAS, NOT
COORDINATING WITH ANY CITIES
ALONG THE WAY.
>> HE SAYS ACTUALLY HE WASN'T
SENDING MIGRANTS -- I WANT TO BE
CLEAR WHAT HE'S SAYING COMPARED
TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW.
HE'S SAYING THAT HE WASN'T
SENDING BUSES DIRECTLY TO NEW
YORK CITY.
BUT THAT HE HEARD YOU
COMPLAINING ABOUT IT, AND THEN
HE THOUGHT, OKAY, YEAH, I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND SEND SOME
BUSES TO NEW YORK.
ARE YOU SAYING HE'S LYING?
>> YES, I AM.
THERE ARE DOCUMENTS -- THERE IS
A DOCUMENT THAT HE HAD MIGRANTS
AND ASYLUM SEEKERS SIGN THAT
SPECIFICALLY STATE THEY WOULD BE
GOING TO NEW YORK AND
WASHINGTON, D.C.
SO IT IS NOT ONLY I'M SAYING
HE'S LYING, BUT HIS DOCUMENTS
ARE SAYING HE'S LYING.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT,
WHICH IS JUST THIS TRIO OF
HEALTH CRISES THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH HERE IN NEW YORK.
POLIO CASE IDENTIFIED OUTSIDE
THE CITY IN ROCKLAND COUNTY, NEW
YORK.
THE CONCERN OF OFFICIALS IS
THAT, YEAH, THIS MAY BE ONE
CASE, BUT THERE COULD BE SEVERAL
HUNDREDS.
THERE COULD BE ASYMPTOMATIC
FOLKS WHO ARE CARRYING THIS.
IS NEW YORK CITY PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH A POLIO OUTBREAK?
>> YES, IT IS SO IMPORTANT AND
WHEN I LOOK OVER MY LIFE, MY
LIFE HAS SHOWN THE IMPORTANCE OF
CRISES AND BUILDING THE RIGHT
TEAM.
OUR COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH, AND OUR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND MENTAL
HYGIENE, WE ARE DEALING WITH A
TRIFECTA.
COVID IS STILL VERY MUCH HERE.
POLIO WE HAVE IDENTIFIED POLIO
IN OUR SEWAGE.
AND WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH THE
MONKEYPOX CRISIS.
BUT THE TEAM IS THERE.
AND WE'RE COORDINATING.
AND WE'RE ADDRESSING THE THREATS
AS THEY COME BEFORE US AND WE'RE
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH THEM AND
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> ANY WORRIES ABOUT THESE NEW
GUIDELINES ON MONKEYPOX WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW TO ADMINISTER
MEDICATIONS?
>> OUR TEAM HERE IN NEW YORK,
THE NEW MANNER OF PUTTING IT
UNDER THE SKIN, MY DOCTORS AND
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS UPDATED
ME ON THIS NEW METHOD OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS STATING
THIS ALLOWS US TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF VACCINES THAT WE CAN
DO.
AND WE HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT THE
CDC AND OTHER GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IS GOING TO GIVE US GOOD ADVICE
AND WE ARE GOING TO COMPLY WITH
THE RULING.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO COVID, THE
CDC IS ALSO OUT WITH SOME NEW
GUIDELINES.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND PUT
THOSE UP.
IN GENERAL, TALKING ABOUT
REMOVING SOCIAL DISTANCING, SOME
QUARANTINE MEASURES, CONTACT
TRACING LIMITED TO HOSPITALS AND
HIGH RISK SITUATIONS, AND THEN
IN SCHOOLS, WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS
SO ESSENTIAL AS THEY'RE
REOPENING, REMOVING COHORTING
RECOMMENDATION AND ALSO REMOVING
THE TEST TO STAY RECOMMENDATION.
DO YOU THINK THESE ARE THE RIGHT
MOVES WHEN IT COMES TO NEW YORK
CITY?
>> WELL, I THINK THE CDC, THEY
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY SHOWED US HOW
TO NAVIGATE OUR WAY THROUGH THE
COVID CRISIS.
AND NOW IN NEW YORK CITY, WE
HAVE DONE THINGS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT.
BUT WE ALWAYS COMPLY WITH THE
CDC AND WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN PIVOTING AND SHIFTING AS
COVID HAS CONTINUED TO PIVOT AND
SHIFT.
IT IS A FORMIDABLE OPPONENT.
I SAID THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
SO WE WILL FOLLOW THE CDC
GUIDELINES, BUT IN SOME CASES
BECAUSE WE HAVE A TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DO THE THINGS WE BELIEVE IS
GOING TO KEEP NEW YORKERS SAFE.
>> ALL RIGHT, MAYOR, APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.